اعتبر الديوان الملكي في المغرب ان حزب
العداله والتنميه اصدر بيانا تضمن تجاوزات
غير مسؤوله ومغالطات خطيره عن علاقات
المغرب مع اسرائيل وربطها بالتطورات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله نعلم جميعا
وقع القضيه الفلسطينيه على وجدان المغاربه
وهي تاتي في نفس المرتبات قضيه الوحده
الترابيه وبالتالي فان قوه ديون سياسيه من
خلال عشر سنوات تحاول اللعب على عواطف
المغاربه من خلال مزايده بقضيه الفلسطينيه
وبالتالي لا يمكن استغلال التحولات
الاقليميه للمشاهده بهدف عوده انتخابيا او
سياسويا الديوان الملكي في المغرب اوضح ان
القضيه الفلسطينيه من اولويات السياسه
الخارجيه للعاهل المغربي الملك محمد
السادس بالاخذ دول الملكي تجهز العداله
والتنميه حيل تطورات ديال القضيه يعبر عن
انزعاج واضح من خلال البلاغ ولغته من
المواقف التي يعبر عليها حزب العداله
والتنميه عشر سنوات من التدبير في الحكومه
للعداله والتنميه ومشاركه اكثر من 14 وزير
وكون رئيس حكومه سابق سعد الدين العثماني
وزير الخارجيه في لحظه من اللحظات تقتضي
ان يفهم ان المخطط والذي يراس
للخارجيه هو ملك البلاد في رساله مباشره
الى اخوان المغرب اعتبر الديوان الملكي
المغربي ان مواقف الرباط لا تخدع
للمزايدات السياسيه او للحملات الانتخابيه
الضيقه فيما العداله والتنميه طالب قيادته
وقواعده بعدم التعليق باي شكل من الاشكال
تكراره هجوم حزب العداله والتنميه المعارض
على الدبلوماسيه المغربيه على خلفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه دفع بحسب مراقبين
السلطات المغربيه الى اصدار بيان شديد
اللهجه يوضح مواقف الرباط من القضيه
الفلسطينيه ويوضح طبيعه استئناف العلاقات
المغربيه الاسرائيليه عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط